my name is Mike Lee Williams I work at
Cloudera and this is a talk about
federated learning which is a way of
doing machine learning that gets around
to concerns you might have when you're
doing machine learning in a distributed
environment one is that you're
compromising the privacy of the people
who gave you the training data and two
it's just bad news to move lots of data
around can we mitigate some of those
engineering problems and we probably
won't have time for questions but I'd
love to talk about this stuff so hit me
up on slack on Twitter on email or just
around the conference today um I've
become this is not group therapy but
I've become pretty down on machine
learning over the last couple of years
for reasons if you're in the keynote
you're probably familiar with plus the
whole surveillance state thing and
federated learning is one of the things
that sort of has given me my mojo back I
think this is a really cool technology
that is has the potential to make
machine learning much less dangerous
while also allowing it us to employ it
in the situations where it can do the
most good so I'm really excited about
this though I think it's very cool the
URL for the slides is down there so if
you can't follow my preposterous accent
or you want to know what I was supposed
to say and so what I actually said then
the presenter notes are in there as well
so if I really want to show how cool
this was I would have made this the
subtitle but there weren't enough
characters if you have a Venn diagram
with like distributed systems AI
differential privacy homomorphic
encryption IOT deep learning all that
good stuff that buzzword bingo stuff
federated learning is right in the
middle of that and then if you add
crappy pseudo code you now at the set
that contains this talk and I'm half
joking we really are going to touch on
all of those topics but at a high level
I'm not an expert in all or really any
of them if I'm honest the goal here is
to get you excited um with that said
well you don't need a background in all
those topics you need to know what
machine learning is and this is AI you
see this image do the rounds on Twitter
if anyone knows who made it let me know
so I'd love to give credit I think it's
the most concise description of what
machine learning is for a CS audience
which I assume not all but many of you
are
is the box at the bottom there it's a
set of algorithms that takes in data and
answers that correspond to those data
and infers a set of rules that maps from
the one to the other and I could have
said that in much more formal functional
programming language but what I couldn't
actually fit in more formal language
because I don't understand that stuff
but that's the basic idea that's kind of
all there is to it obviously what's
going on in that box is kind of the
devil is in the detail and people make
millions because of what happens in that
box but we don't need to know the
details to a great extent for the
purpose of this talk that's a little bit
abstract and functional programming so I
want to be a bit more concrete I want to
build a classifier that can tell the
difference between foo and bar in order
to do that I need lots of images of foo
not just one image many images and I
need lots of images of bar now I'm a
very ambitious researcher so I'm going
to build a 3-way classifier and I'm
going to add in a third class about
jokes of slow burner the last joke but
then I put all this stuff in my Amstrad
here and then machine learning occurs
and out comes a classifier the details
of how that happens like I say not super
important for the purpose of this talk
but one thing that is important for the
purpose of this talk are those 3 red
arrows on the left what happened there
that training dates are all those images
started life in general not on my
computer they start on other people's
machines so I had to move them and that
created a couple of new problems that I
didn't have before I started doing this
one is privacy um I might not be
comfortable sharing my hard drive full
of Dave Grohl photos with you because
you know I'm you might think that's
weird
or you might be a rival Dave Grohl
picture collector for some reason I
don't want to share those photos with
you
in general I think many of us are
comfortable uncomfortable about sharing
our data with each other or with tech
companies in particular these days for
example if you've got a kid you might
feel uncomfortable about putting their
image online even in a private setting
and some private photo album because you
know somewhere it's being ingested into
some machine learning algorithm it's
suppose I'm some kind of like non
evil tech company and I want to build a
feature that does better URL Auto
completion in a browser the training
data for that is people's browser
history I don't know about you but I'm
not going to contribute to the training
data for that model if you use any kind
of medical device that takes
measurements of your body a glucose
sensor a SmartWatch whatever you're
probably pretty uncomfortable about
sharing that maybe even with your doctor
certainly with your insurance company
and some random medical device
manufacturer you want to retain control
of that data there's a custodian of
medical data you might have very good
meritorious reasons for wanting to pull
that data with other custodians like
maybe if all these folks got together
they could cure cancer by pooling all
their data but they can't for very good
reasons
hipper in the US similar regulations
elsewhere that prevents the knave
pooling of data in one place if you have
any customers any users at all anywhere
in the European Union you're constrained
by gdpr which came into force last May
that here it is in a nutshell and it
basically requires you to minimize the
extent to which you collect and retain
data and that includes machine learning
training data and even if you don't care
about your own data your own dave grohl
picture collection even if you don't
work in a regulated industry even if you
don't have data that belongs to people
in the European Union you should still
care because having data is bad news you
do not want data data is expensive to
acquire it's expensive to a store and
storing it incurs risks as well data is
kind of like nuclear waste in that sense
like you get something good you get
sugar high when you first get it and now
you've got a problem that ideas work
tightly much more detail in this talk
you should leave the room now and watch
this talk it's really really good 15
minutes very funny it's on YouTube about
the idea that data is not doesn't come
without long-term costs so we're in the
situation where our users don't want to
share our data we can't and would rather
avoid having it for various reasons and
this seems to be in tension with this
goal of doing machine learning remember
one of the inputs of machine learning is
data and we're now in this world where
people are reluctant to give it us and
we don't want it
in addition to those increasingly
salient concerns about privacy there are
these practical trends relating to
hardware that affect whether it's a good
idea to do that naive thing of just
moving all the training data to one
machine it becomes less of a good idea
and the big reason for that is these
things so much training data these days
so much the data we'd like to use the
train machine learning model starts life
on devices with non-permanent network
connection cellular cellular connections
bandwidth is relatively expensive on
those devices it's not free to upload
your all your baby photos from that
device you're asking a lot of the user
and in some cases the data might even be
just straight-up too big to move related
to the the financial cost of using the
bandwidth is this one how are the radio
antennae in a phone consumes a
disproportionate amount of power more
than the screen in some situations so we
don't just wanna naively require mobile
users to upload all their data that's
the bad news of these secular hardware
trends the good news is this stuff
increasingly these devices on the edge
have specialized hardware for supporting
machine learning workloads you've got a
fancy end video system on a chip there
on the right right and left sorry and an
iPhone on the other side these have
specialized hardware for doing machine
learning and in some I mean certainly
the iPhone is faster here than my my
ancient laptop here which on the other
hand does have a keyboard that works
unlike new laptops and these devices are
just sitting there waiting to be tapped
into we don't need to provide the
capital to invest in a data center we
also don't need to provide the climate
control to use them they're there
waiting to be used and they are the data
is already on them
so that induces this setting this
interesting idea of federated learning
which we're now ready to sort of specify
what that situation is is this we want
to train machine learning models using
data that is partitioned across several
nodes but for a variety of reasons
including privacy and practicalities we
can't just move the data between the
nodes or on
the server so how can we produce a
machine learning model in this situation
I use the word node there deliberately
the sort of abstract computer science
word no node rather than mobile phone
because mobile phone is perhaps the most
obvious example of a node but an equally
legitimate node is a country a legal
entity some other device a car anywhere
where data is trapped inside a partition
restricted by law or practicalities or
preferences from being moved so what do
we do well we do federated learning of
course this would be a weird talk if
that wasn't what we did in this
situation federated learning is a family
of algorithms and I'm gonna talk about a
specific algorithm namely federated
averaging that algorithm was published
in a paper that came out in 2016 it's a
relatively readable paper by the
standards these things I do recommend it
I've got a list of suggested reading
that I'll flash up at the end as well
it's um it the reason I've chosen this
album to explain is many of the
algorithms that have come since build on
top of this album they're it's actually
variations on the theme of federated
averaging additionally by the standards
of distributed systems algorithms this
is a pretty simple one this is not Paxos
we're not going to be here for the next
what we've got 30 minutes explaining
this algorithm is going to take me five
minutes to explain in fact it's so
simple that two things are surprising
but one thing is surprising one thing is
not surprising it's so simple it's kind
of surprising that it works to be honest
and we'll get into the implications of
that later it's not surprising however
that it was published in 1990 in Jeff
Dean's undergraduate thesis without him
realizing it well this is his
undergraduate thesis it's an extremely
simple algorithm and it's kind of the
obvious thing to do if you know a little
bit about machine learning it's not it
won't surprise any of you who have
trained a neural network what's going to
happen credit to the 2016 paper they do
a lot more work to figure out the
implications of when this thing will
work and when it won't work both in a
mathematical sense and also in a
practical sense clearly the environment
in which we're doing machine learning
has trained a lot since 1990 I don't
want to suggest Jeff Dean's
undergraduate thesis was the last word
on this algorithm
so let's get started what does this
album do I'm going to explain it twice
once with these diagrams that were drawn
by my colleague grant Custer who I'll
mention again later in the talk and then
I'm gonna explain it again with this
infamous crappy pseudocode I mentioned
so if you listen to both you should get
it by the end here's how the world
starts we've got a server and notes and
there are four nodes to illustrate here
but there might be you know arbitrarily
many greater than one nodes here and the
nodes are of course where the data is is
and the server is some agent that
orchestrates this whole process is going
to be the custodian of the shared
modeled everyone's training the server
starts life with a machine learning
model on it and that's denoted by that
straight line which you can kind of
think of as a linear regression line
that model is completely uninitialized
it's random essentially it has the
structure of a machine learning model so
in the case of a linear model it's y
equals ax plus plate ax plus B it has a
and it has B but the values of a and B a
random its it has no predictive power
but it does in its structure encapsulate
the kind of machine learning we want to
be doing the next thing that happens is
a copy of that model
is sent to the notes the notes now have
that model and they infer from receiving
that model that they refer to things
they're supposed to do one is we're
training models of this type so we're
tricked and so it gets y equals a at the
plus play ax plus b and it figures out
okay we're training a linear model or it
receives something with the structure of
a convolutional neural network and it
knows we're training a model with that
architecture it also knows that it is
supposed to take though the weights the
parameters of the model and improve them
by doing the usual thing in machine
learning namely training the model so in
order to train a model it's going to
acquire some training data so each node
here either loads off its disk or
requires and we're using senses some
training data and the white dots are
supposed to denote that so where this is
again in this linear model so there are
cloud of dots and we'd like to train
each model to better fit the data on
that particular note note that each node
has different training data I have
photos of my friends and family you have
photos of your friends and family
they're not on we don't share them
so each node trains a bit so let me just
page battles and forwards the model on
each node becomes a better model of the
data on that node it does this using
some gradient descent I said we didn't
need to know a lot about the details of
machine learning this is one thing we do
need to know a little bit about gradient
descent is commonly how you train
machine learning models and the idea is
you set up a surface a hyper surface a
surface whose height tells you how bad
the model is the higher you are up on
this surface the worse your model is so
you would like to move downhill ideally
to the lowest point on the surface and
the gradient descent algorithm works
like this you look around in each
direction you say which of these
directions goes down the steepest so
this way goes uphill I'm not going to go
in that direction this way goes downhill
slowly and this way goes off the edge of
the podium so that's the way I want to
go that's the steepest downhill so I
take one step in that direction and
that's a step of gradient descent and
generally speaking you want to end up at
the lowest point on the surface and
there are no guarantees about this but
if you follow this algorithm you often
do in practice end up at the lowest
point the lowest point of course is the
point on the surface where it's uphill
in every direction that might go wrong
that algorithm but that's not the point
of this talk in federated learning what
the server is instructing the noes to do
is take some steps you don't need to
walk until you find the lowest point on
your surface just take a few steps and
get back to me so each of them has done
that they've taken a few steps to
improve the model and then they get back
to the server by uploading the model to
the server the model then does what you
might have guessed from the name of the
algorithm the federated averaging it
takes the average of the model let me
page backwards and forwards the model
the server just took the average of the
four models it received from their notes
average here is defined as it takes the
element-wise average of all of the
weights in the model so remember y
equals ax plus B that linear model what
it's doing here is taking the average
separately of all the A's and of all the
B's and the average model is y equals
the average of the A's times X plus the
average of the B's more complicated but
the same basic idea for a neural network
find the correspond
list of weights in each model and take
their average separately that average
model encapsulate sin firm ation that
was present on every note it kind of is
a function of all the training data and
then we repeat that what I just
described was one round of federated
learning the server then sends this
newly averaged model back as the
starting point to the notes for another
round of gradient descent and they send
their improve miles back we take an
average and we do that n times where n
is a function of our patience crucially
nope the important thing that happened
here no training data left any of the
nodes which means we've preserved
privacy in the obvious way that we
haven't uploaded their data to the
server or to each other we'll talk about
the extent to which we've actually
preserve privacy later and we've used we
have used up significantly less their
bandwidth and that's because machine
learning is basically lossy compression
in a data set with a hundred examples
100 XY pairs and a linear model we are
compressing 200 numbers to two numbers
it's a hundredfold compression that's
generally true in machine learning
there's more train there's more bytes in
the training data than there are in the
model so we've clearly saved bandwidth
and that often means we've saved power
as well for these devices and a nice
little side effect from the point of
view of our bosses is we've saved us
money if we don't own these devices but
we own the server we did a much cheaper
computation on the server than we would
otherwise have done had we consolidated
the data all in one place taking
averages is much simpler than doing back
propagation for example you don't need a
GPU to take averages so that was the
algorithm as a cartoon let's look at
this crappy pseudocode this is a round
of federated learning so this is kind of
pseudo Python I mean I think it's
syntactically legal but it wouldn't work
first thing we do is instruct each node
to train and return its model so we're
going to do that each model each node
has a trained model method we'll call
that and we'll accumulate the results in
an updated model a list of all the
models we will then stick that list as
the input into a function federated
averaging which we'll see in a second
but is going to take the average of
those models obviously and as
to the model on the server and then we
will communicate back to the nodes we'll
say for each node replace your model
with the model on the server that's it
that's a round of federated learning the
pseudocode is much easier to explain
than the figures but I like the figures
the devil in the detail is that
federated averaging function and what
that looks like will depend strongly on
what kind of model your training what
class of model you're training and what
machine learning framework you're using
so I'm going to show you an example for
pi touch which is a deep learning
framework this federated averaging
function is going to take the weighted
average by which I mean we're going to
weight the amount of attention we pay to
each node in proportion to how much data
they had so if I've got thousands of
photos of dave grohl and you've got to
because you're not insane
then we're going to pay more attention
to me unfortunately when we when we
compute that average because I have more
information about what this model should
look like and this weighted average just
encodes that idea in order to compute a
weighted average the first thing you
have to do is fight figure out the total
amount of data and this is what doing
that might look like we just want the
total number of photos of Dave Grohl in
the whole network then we are going to
prepare what an uninitialized data
structure to hold the weights of the
model and in this case we're going to do
that by just taking a copy of one of the
models that we got that from the nodes
here you see the specifics of pi talks
that state dick method is a PI touch
thing that gives you a dictionary in
fact a data structure that holds the
parameters of the model in this in
earning also records the structure of
the model in terms of the kind of
transformations that are being done
that's a PI to watch detail it's not
super important what is important but
also not interesting enough to go
through line by line is this step where
we take the federated averaging and all
the indentation is broke there that
after the first line there the weight
sum and the last line in that block
should be indented what we're doing
there is going through each location in
the network and forming that average and
replacing the value in the average model
with the sum that's kind of fiddly to
explain if you stare at this and if I
were to fix the indentation it would
make more sense but it really is as
simple as it seems we're just taking the
average of all the A's
and forming a new model where a is the
average so what do we get if we actually
do this this is the lost curve we'd see
if we trained a model like this this is
remember I said gradient descent you're
looking at a surface and trying to go
downhill this is not that surface this
is rather how high you were on that
surface as a function of time and
clearly you're going downhill that's
what you want to see when you do machine
learning the green line here is the one
you care about the green line here is
the performance how bad the model is of
the average model on the server and
that's clearly getting better quickly
and reaches a very good level of
performance what would the y axis there
is mean squared error which is one way
of measuring how bad your model is and
the x axis there is basically time
that's the Green Line the orange line is
significant as well so I spread I split
data over a number of nodes 18 nodes and
one of them every node got the same
amount of data but one of them I asked
not to participate in the network just
to train with its own data that's the
orange line it does get better
it is better than at the end of the time
at time 30 it's better than it was at
time zero but it's nowhere near as good
as the federated model and that's for a
very simple reason it has less training
data this one has one 80th the training
data of the federated Network the
federated Network doesn't have all that
data in one place it has access to it
mediated by this weird algorithm but it
implicitly has a record of that data in
a collectively trained model the non
participant does not and that's the kind
of a golden rule of machine learning the
more training data you have in general
the better your model will be so that's
all kind of abstract and dry so let's
let's play a game if I can get my screen
to work this is turbofan tycoon if you
go to turbofan fast forward Labs comm
you'll see this game when you played
universal paper clips hands up if you
playing universal paper clips this is
like a an eat your greens version of
universal paper clips universal paper
clips is a game and a thought experiment
about what happens if a super
intelligent being took over the world
with the cost function maximize the
number of paper
whoops in the universe this is not that
this is just maximize the amount of
dollars in your checking account
which is even worse in many ways and
we're going to do that by having a
factory that with turbines that generate
revenue while they're running and costs
money to replace or repair they cost
less money to repair than they do for a
place so we'd like to repair them rather
than wait for them to explode this is a
predictive maintenance problem let me
set time going forward and you will see
that I start to generate money that plot
on the right hand side that's my income
going up as a function of time very
nicely but you will also see I've got
competitors who are doing differently
sometimes my income drops because I have
to replace a turbine sometimes other
people's income drops because they
replace a turbine
I've just been waiting for these things
to explode but now I've realized that's
a really stupid idea I should fix up
them after some amount of time and the
first strategy a implement is kind of
like when you replace the oil in your
car after 5,000 miles it's just a fixed
every 200 hours or whatever it is I
forget I'm going to replace that turbine
and that is going to anticipate some of
the failure it's ideally most of them
and but of course that's not an optimal
strategy I will fail to intervene for
some of these turbines and I will
intervene too soon for others it would
be better to use all the sensor data on
the left on each of these turbines to
anticipate what's going to happen so
eventually I'm going to generate enough
revenue to reach this state of
enlightenment that allows me to hire a
data scientist and she's going to look
at my ridiculous correct preventative
maintenance thing and say that's idiotic
why don't you do machine learning with
the data you've got with the failures
you've seen so I'll say okay that sounds
like a good idea let's do that so I take
this set of training data I've got and
she gives me a machine learning model
back that improves the performance of
the model I'm green and I'm starting to
catch up with the other folks which is
very nice and if I wait long enough
let's speed things up a lot then from
above an invitation will come to join a
federated network eventually and that's
the best of all possible worlds I do not
have to reveal the embarrassing ways in
which I broke my machines my retain
control over my data this sensitive
industrial data but I now have
a model that is based on not just a few
failures that I've seen but the many
hundreds of failures that took place in
the federated Network and I mean this is
random so I'm not actually in the lead
yet but I should move into the lead area
I'm in the lead now and if you let time
run forward then the game finishes when
you get three million dollars or you can
keep playing and you can go back to the
bad strategies and so on
federated learning is not happening in
the browser this is kind of cheating you
don't need other people to be playing at
the same time here this is a static
pre-trained model and the idea is like I
say eat your greens a bit learn a bit of
machine learning but I think that if you
play that you will learn a bit about
what's going on here more clearly I made
that in collaboration with my colleague
grant Custer who also all the figures in
this slide that don't look really bad he
did as well he's a wonderful designer
front-end engineer and there's the URL
one more time let me go to that to this
figure this is actually the real model
the green one is the real model you
upgrade to when you accept the
invitation to join the federated network
and I made it by randomly distributing
training data across the nodes now is
that realistic right we don't I take
photos of my family and friends and
where I live and you take photos of your
family and friends and where you live
the label distributions on our two sets
of training data are different it's not
realistic if I wanted to play this game
to randomly distribute photos of my
family and your family across our two
computers that's weird so this is not a
realistic simulation in that sense it's
not the end of the world for turbofan
failures I assume they fail in the same
way everywhere maybe they don't I don't
know but we'd like to do something a bit
more realistic in the set of photos of
humans or turbofans I'm going to do it
with this data set which is kind of
about the hello world of machine
learning this is M mist these are 60,000
I think 70,000 handwritten digits taken
from envelopes these as if codes people
wrote on envelopes and the goal in the
80s was to solve this problem with
various computer vision strategies and
of course deep learning one and the rest
is history we're going to use this data
set to verify whether the more realistic
scenario in which
data is differently distributed across
the nodes of the network actually
results in a good model so there are
number of ways of doing that
distribution one is just not do
federated learning we could have a non
federated data set where the numbers are
distributed the labels in our dataset
are distributed like this and that is a
uniform distribution roughly ten ten
percent of each node each class is in
the dataset is taken from each class if
we federated at in the way we did for
the turbofan prototype we'll end up with
smaller data sets that look like this
they're still uniformly distributed
across the classes there'll be ten of
them but this is what they look like
more realistic might be let's say I
really like writing zeroes maybe because
I live in Vermont where zip codes start
with zero and you live in New York City
so you write ones a lot more than me the
point is this is unequal distribution
I've written 0 90% of the time 10% of
the time I've written one of the other
digits randomly chosen and there are
eight more of these data sets and I can
do federated learning like that and I've
left a gap and you can probably guess
what I've left that gap for the extreme
example of I only ever write zeros I
just really like zeros and I just sit
around writing them all day long and you
feel the same way about ones which is I
don't know why you're laughing you're
weird too so we're now gonna do we're
going to train with these four
approaches to in the first case not
federating the data and then the other
three federating the data and here's
what happens this is the wildest figure
in the talk it's kind of boring in some
ways but it's actually really I think
the interesting one the blue line is the
non federated model and you can almost
not see how perfect it is that's how
perfect it is we've got that loss curve
on the top so the lower is better on the
last curve it's exactly the same really
as the accuracy accuracy can clearly be
no better than 100% and we'd like it to
be 100% so the blue curve gets very good
very quickly it's very good straight
away basically and if you've played with
em inist you'll know it's not hard to
get a very good accuracy with the M&S
data set then the orange curve is kind
of like turbofan is a uniform
distribution that model reaches the same
performance as the blue curve pretty
quickly not quite as quickly it takes a
few rounds of federated learning for
this data sort of
see across this weird algorithm but it
does get their greens surprisingly the
same thing this extremely biased data
set that wouldn't have a hope if these
work if these nodes with 90% zeros and
90% ones were to try and train a network
on their own they wouldn't have a hope
in hell of getting this level of
performance they just don't have enough
examples of most of the classes and yet
via this weird federated averaging
algorithm they reach that excellent
performance the red one for me is the
weird amazing line these are ten workers
communicating only through models not
through data that are able to send data
in some vague sense across a network to
learn from each other's data set
it's obviously not very good it reaches
like 85% accuracy which is not good for
M nist but it's a lot better than chance
a chance model on em mr. model that just
rolls a 10-sided dice to label it would
have ten percent accuracy obviously so
this is way way better than chance which
tells you that we've learned quite a lot
even in this extreme scenario this is
completely wild to me now I was very
vague about information seeping across
the algorithm very informal in a way
that many of you were the CS or math
background probably will make quite
uncomfortable by that and that brings me
to all the bad things about federated
learning so I've hopefully got you
really excited now I'm gonna bum you out
by telling you what's wrong here and
this is you could more charitably call
these positive spin these areas of
active research one of them is does it
actually work well in general does it
work and if so why does it work it would
be nice and certainly reassuring to know
the answers to those questions secondly
are we actually reducing consumption of
resources in any way three oh no we're
now in distributed systems land this is
scary for are we actually guaranteeing
privacy so let's talk about each of
these in turn
does it work here's a picture of an
alchemist which sort kind of tells you
the answer to the question if you ask me
why federated learning works or will it
work in a particular case where work
here is defined as converges on a
solution that is about as good as the
solution you'd get if you had all the
data in one place I can't tell you the
answer to that question no one can you
can prove federated
averaging in particular will work for
linear models there's another algorithm
that you can prove will work for another
class of machine learning model called
support vector machine you cannot prove
anything about it for neural networks
which is not surprising you can't prove
anything about neural networks
unfortunately this is a problem
particularly a problem for federated
learning because the definition of work
is obscure to me in real situations I
could plot the blue line on that graph
the benchmark because I was able to
consolidate the data in one place but I
wouldn't normally be able to do that if
I'm doing federated learning the whole
point of federated learning is you can't
consolidate the data in one place so you
have a model that maybe is doing better
than chance but is it actually working
you don't know I should note that if
like I say if you're from a CS
background this is not an unusual
problem in machine learning at all and
machine learning people have developed a
fairly strong stomach for this situation
perhaps too strong and I really
recommend as a talk by lui here me and
Ben req that was given it in Europe's
last year it was 18 months ago it's on
YouTube it's 15 minutes very very
accessible like keynote address thing
about this idea of alchemy and deep
learning
ideally in deep learning we they've sort
of accepted they're not going to be able
to prove results but ideally they might
be doing something a bit more scientific
something a bit formal in their
experimentation but there is a view
somewhat self-deprecating view that what
they're actually doing is alchemy and
this talk is a great exploration of the
idea that I really highly recommend so
that was does it work and the answer is
maybe
this is this what about this issue of
resources I sold you
federated learning among other things as
something that would reduce the amount
of resources required of the nodes in
the network in terms of bandwidth and
power and it may do that but it is still
a pretty demanding workload we're asking
a phone to train a neural network for
example that's still you know that may
not be you know play candy crush for
eight hours on a flight but it's still
pretty demanding there are lots of ways
you can imagine of changing federated
averaging to reduce the amount of
computation required of the nodes and
just as like an illustrative example you
can imagine asking nodes to sit out a
round of communication if there
they're training they've done has not
actually resulted in a model that's very
different to the one they received so I
took I took a random took a stochastic
gradient descent step and didn't
actually end up moving very far there's
no need for me to upload a model to the
server because I don't have any news
that's one just one example there are
lots of clever ideas like that that
reduced the communication further we've
then got these problems the generic
endemic horrendous problems you get when
you enter distributed systems land and
most machine learning people are not
really familiar with those I wasn't and
it was a huge bummer when I found out
about them the central the reason these
problems exist is we're now operating at
scale not n equals 4 or N equals 10 like
it was in my examples but really large
scale we're operating at scale and
Murphy's Law is a thing together those
two things mean that anything that can
go wrong will go wrong somewhere in your
network you have to be robust against
all the failure modes this actually has
this this has a name in physics that I'm
trying to make happen this is called the
totalitarian principle in physics not in
honor of various 20th century
governments but it's rises from the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics it says anything that can
happen will happen in one of the worlds
that's true in distributed systems too
and here are two examples that are
really gonna screw up federated
averaging in particular federated
averaging will not proceed to the next
round until it is heard back from every
single worker that means federated
averaging will only proceed as fast as
the slowest worker in the network so if
you've got a straggler which you're very
likely to do in a real federated
learning situation different amounts of
data different hardware different
network connections on actually node
this is not a perfectly symmetrical
spherical data center anymore then
you're very likely to proceed quite
slowly as slow as the slowest Network if
one of those nodes drops its connection
you're it's a disaster you just just
stuck you just sit there like an idiot
for the rest of the time of the universe
well how do we fix these problems there
are fairly obvious things to do we are
somewhat hamstrung again by the fact we
don't know why federated learning works
like you might think okay well he didn't
get back to me within 5 minutes I'll
just move on
does that break training does the model
still converge on a solution we don't
have a good way of reasoning about that
and it remains like an empirical science
to find out if those things we might do
work we can't prove things like we can
in you know Paxos or whatever and then
the final thing is privacy I said by not
moving the data we are helping preserve
the privacy of our users and we are in a
very obvious way like I did not upload
my Dave Grohl photos and that was great
that made me feel good but the problem
boils down to this it's not in general
impossible to infer from a trained
machine learning model what the training
data looks like that's the problem it
can be a hard problem it can actually be
a trivial problem as well but it is more
usually quite a hard problem but that
hard problem is suddenly attracting a
lot of attention because of ideas like
federated learning federated learning is
like painting a target on your back like
if you work in security you're familiar
with his idea suddenly these payloads
have become very attractive because
we're doing federated learning precisely
because the data is sensitive so it's
attracted a lot of interest recently and
here is my favorite example of that this
is a pretty dense paper this is a hard
problem to invert this image recognition
model but on the Left what you've got is
an original training example that
occurred on one of the nodes in a
network something like federated
learning not exactly the same thing but
same basic idea on the right you've got
a reconstructed image that image was not
even reconstructed by the server it was
reconstructed by another peer node in
the network you don't need him to be
even need to be in a position of
authority in this algorithm to do this
kind of attack and clearly it's not the
original it's a photocopy of a photocopy
but also clearly we have compromised the
privacy of this gentleman we now know
what he looks like you could pick him
out of a lineup now
it was hard specialized non
generalizable work to do this attack but
these attacks exist and mitigating
against them there are a couple of
strategies and this is very much an area
of active research fall into two buckets
one is having the nodes encrypt
essentially the data before they upload
it the second is having them add noise
to the data before they upload it and I
said data then I shouldn't
the models before they upload them so
encrypt the model or or add noise to the
model you have you can't just encrypt
the model like using a regular
encryption algorithm you have to encrypt
it in such a way that that averaging
operation still works you don't want the
server to be able to decrypt the model
either and that is for example
homomorphic encryption the idea there is
you've encrypted the numbers in such a
way that those primitive algebraic
operations still work that is
computationally ruinously expensive but
the good news is most of the cost of
that falls on the server that has to do
the algebraic operations not on the
nodes that have to do the encryption so
it's a it's a tenable approach secure
aggregation is basically the same idea
in the sense that I don't actually
understand the difference differential
privacy is the other one I do understand
this one so differential privacy is a
really nice elegant idea let's say I
want I know the height of everyone in
this room it's right I want to know the
average height of people in this room
what I might do is ask you to give me
your heights and you're saying no I
that's very sensitive piece of
information I'm not willing to tell you
my height so what I'll ask you to do now
is okay let's do this differentially
privately I want you to go out your
laptops and add a random number with a
mean of zero normally distribute it to
your height so add a number between
minus 10 and plus 10 normally
distributed to your height you all do
that and tell me the result none of you
told me your height well one of you
might have drawn zero but I don't know
that none of you told me your height but
if I take those numbers you gave me and
compute the average on average I will
get the right answer I will still
recover the average that's differential
privacy in a nutshell it is usually
applied to raw data but in this case
we're going to apply it to the model
we're uploading we're going to add noise
to the model and the averaging operation
that the server does will still recover
the average model the devil is in the
detail of course how much noise can we
add how should it be structured the
noise and given those choices what does
that imply about whether we converge on
the on a good model and things like that
it's tricky stuff it's working again
work in progress so I got you excited
about federated learning I told you
about all the open problems now but if
you're actually still with me here's
when you might use it is when it's
applicable as a rat's they don't do it
for fun do do it for fun it's good
fun but you should only really do it in
practice if you can't consolidate your
data in one place consolidating your
data in one place is going to be easier
and you in general you won't be able to
consolidate your dental in one place
because one of these two situations
obtains either you concern about privacy
or you're concerned about the resources
of the devices on which the data lives
that doesn't actually rule out a lot of
situations there are a lot of real-world
situations where that's true and most of
them we've touched on in this talk to
that we haven't risk modeling so
insurance and that's an obvious
application of federated learning
because insurance often insures against
events we don't particularly want to
share details of so you can buy
kidnapping insurance you can buy cyber
intrusion insurance the data for that is
Goldust insurance companies don't want
to share it with each other customers
don't want to share it with insurance
companies and additionally in this
particular case the incremental data
value of more data to the model is very
high because these events are so rare
this is a really good use case for
federated learning then you've got
unpretty things things like JIRA or if
slack romp let Prem slack would be
another example JIRA and slack would
like to build smart features into their
models but they can't because they don't
have direct access to a representative
training data they have their own eating
their own dog food use of these products
but by definition those are unusual
patterns in the data they'd like their
customers data but their customer for
obvious reasons won't give them to them
federated learning might be an approach
that would be useful in that situation
finally some practical advice if you
want to do this establish a performance
benchmark you're doing federated
learning because you can't put all the
data in one place but you should do the
next best thing put some of the data in
one place make some fake data whatever
get a back-of-the-envelope idea of how
good this model is going to be and
verify using that back-of-the-envelope
idea that the model would be improved by
access to more training data all
federated learning is is a really
complicated way of getting access to
more training data so you should only do
it if getting access to more training
data is going to help you don't have to
be doing deep learning I mentioned it a
lot in this talk just because it's you
know hot but you could be using linear
models or SVM's in these approaches as
well
you can't by the way do this approach
federated averaging with trees or
decision forests and the reason for that
is trees are different shapes you can't
meaningfully take the average of two
trees because they're different shapes
so federated averaging won't work there
are other approaches that do work but
out of the box you have to be able to
take the average for federated averaging
to work the two libraries I recommend if
you don't want to implement this stuff
yourself and you don't because
distributed systems and networks are PI
sift intensive flow federated tensorflow
federated art is obviously going to be
where she's you a you should start
you're already in the tensorflow
ecosystem pi sift is an independent
open-source project I like and then you
know the upside downside of working on a
field that doesn't really kind of work
here or has a lot of open problems is
you should read papers and I'm gonna
finish by showing a bunch of papers that
I think you might enjoy reading there's
a couple of blog posts there one we
wrote cloud era is at the top that's
kind of a high-level summary of this
talk the party popper next to the
Federation for Firefox one is because I
particularly recommend that if you
google these you'll bear the first
result or if you DuckDuckGo these
they're the first result the Firefox one
is great it's the most detailed
practical blog post about the networking
and distributed systems issues florian
Hartmann sort of piggybacks on the
telemetry system that already exists in
Firefox to use that to handle the
network traffic it's also interesting
because it uses an SVM rather than a
neural network which is you know always
nice to see people rocking it old-school
the papers they're all good but the
party poppers are next to the the
federated averaging paper and then the
PI sift paper the people that introduces
that I'll tweet a link to these slides
but there's a there is again thank you
very much that's it
[Applause]